mi nombre es un andrés tengo 15 años
estoy en negro adoptado
luego llamó darío maiorana mi hermana de
una chiquita una grande y un hermano
[Música]
un día antes de la pandemia era me
levantaba a las 5 me bañaba desayunado
mío la cinta idea para la escuela temer
la ruta
un día de hoy por ejemplo ayer me vi
muerto maté
hoy 50 canastillas de pagar un 40 y
llegué a la casa pero ayer porque las
manos de mancha donde tomates
y así el almuerzo porque no me dan
guardar
enviaremos para el colegio porque no
puede jugar no veamos compañeros
y porque no puedo tener clases
matemáticas
quiero que las cuerdas
no entramos aunque no vemos
[Música]